[Music]
I was the future once said David Cameron
in his last day in office as prime
minister well um as The Spectators cover
piece by Katie bull says this week uh he
is the future once again after rishy
sunak on Monday surprised Everyone by
bringing back David Cameron as his new
foreign secretary uh amid a reshuffle a
bigger reshuffle um I'm joined to
discuss this very surprising development
with uh Kate fall baroness Kate fall who
was uh David Cameron's uh advisor uh for
a long period of time and uh John
Redwood MP I can't think of two better
people to talk about this subject with
um Kate I will start with you uh
everyone was surprised may I ask if you
were surprised did you have an inkling
this was your
thing I had an inkling but only just
before uh that um that um it was
happening and I think yeah I think it
was a very commendable um of rishy to
reach out to to um a tall poppy in his
put a tall poppy in his cabinet um I
think David Cameron has the experience
and status to be really great foreign
secretary at a time when you know the
world is um really in a very difficult
place with Middle East and Ukraine
Rising tensions with China so um yeah I
thought it was a very interesting and
good appointment uh there's been a lot
of talk this week about you know the
fact that he's a serious politician that
he brings skills and experience and so
on uh I suppose the fact that the story
didn't leak might help uh add to the
fact that uh that he is is a proper
politician because um generally when in
the Tory party in the last few years
we're not used to um them being able to
keep surprises it would you describe him
as a consument
professional no he he absolutely is a
consument professional um he he was very
very um good and very focused on that
wider National Security role at his time
in number 10 people often don't realized
that almost 50% of the prime minister's
time is spent on that sort of wide beef
if you include you know home office
Affairs as well and he's he is
passionate about it it was sort of great
and reassuring to see him today I
thought with zilinsky I'm sure he'll be
turning his attention also to the Middle
East and I think when we look to next
year when you've got all these big
elections coming not least with the USA
a sense of um will there be a vacuum in
in in sort of Global Leadership the fact
that you have David Cameron there on the
world stage when Wishy obviously prime
minister does some of that but he'll be
spending quite a lot of time thinking
about the general election so good
reassuring I thought well you say that
Kate but there are quite a lot of
criticisms of David Cameron's foreign
policy as prime minister and perhaps
quite a few very valid criticisms I mean
let's start with uh brexit which
obviously went wrong for him in a big
way uh you could also Point towards
Libya um where he was very much behind
the intervention uh that ended up being
a disaster for the region possibly
creating Isis or certainly bolstering
Isis uh and then lastly of course there
is this issue of China um where he was
very much behind the Golden Age um and
rash Administration appears or appeared
to be uh very different on its position
with China and there are some lots of
questions about the amount of money that
he has taken um possibly to shill for
China in the last few years I mean
that's quite uh that's three rather big
things that um he can be criticized over
on foreign
policy so just dealing with that I mean
starting with brexit look David Cameron
put the question of our membership of
the European Union at a point when
people people were feeling worried about
where that was going to the British
people he argued for us to stay he lost
that argument and resign so I I don't
think that is um a failure I think it's
it would have been failure if he hadn't
put it to the British people um Libya
look one of the most difficult jobs as a
prime minister is that question on your
watch what do you do to save lives often
there's no perfect solution there's a
cost to either thing so that with liya
he went in he was passionately trying to
stop a terrible situation with China I
think that is you know a very
interesting live issue I'm sure John
Redwood will have a view on this look at
the time when David um C was prime
minister he put forward a a strong
Prosperity um sort of narrative with
China but there was always the National
Security the human rights angle you know
the sovereignty issue but also China has
changed and she was only just in place
during that time and look he's moved
towards a much more
authoritarian um um we're running China
we have terrible things happening in
Shing Jang we have what's going on on
Hong Kong and I think you know David
camon will react to China of now not to
uh where it was all those years ago so
that would be my my answer on the
foreign policy
piece John uh I'll bring you in uh
you've seen a lot of reshuffles in your
time what was your reaction to What
happened on
Monday I think it was a great pity um my
advice to Prime Ministers which they
always ignored is not to have General
reshuffles they they are usually bad
news and I've never known one that
suddenly changes fortunes of the
government favorably I think we need
much more professional management of
ministerial talent and MP Talent there
needs to be proper Talent mapping there
needs to be mentoring and encouraging um
ministers need to be given a defined
task and it needs to be reviewed on a
regular basis by the uh immediate
Superior uh so that you don't get to a
point one or two two years in where
you're standing by your phone not
knowing whether you're good bad or
indifferent whether you're going to be
promoted or sacked I it's totally
unacceptable and you create too many
people who don't like you as BR Minister
because quite a few of the people who
sacked particularly deserve to be sacked
it's just some argument about oh we need
to open it up to different types of
people or something I think David
Cameron was more skeptical the most
about res shuffles sort of got talked
into them but this one I think um did
backfire badly as we've seen uh and we
now have to get behind the new team to
try and get the show back on the road
get people talking about what really
matters which is what work are we doing
for the country how are people's lives
going to be better how are the
conservatives going to stop the small
boats get the economy growing and get
inflation down uh as quickly as possible
because those are good aims uh but they
were knocked a bit by the events of the
last few days there is among uh people
in sw1 or Tories in sw1 you do pick up a
certain Nostalgia for the Cameron years
because they came before brexit and the
chaos of brexit and they came before the
pandemic and the disaster of the
pandemic and you do pick up this sense
that in the Cameron years uh possibly
because they're in Coalition uh the Tory
party had uh more drive more sense of
purpose more competence do you agree
with
that no I don't agree with that
formulation I think David's great
achievement was to give us the
referendum I agree with Kate on that was
one of those who wanted a referendum I
was delighted when he saw the wisdom of
doing it I was sad that he backed so
strongly the side that I always thought
the found lose Associated himself with a
set of totally bogus and wildly wrong
economic
forecasts in an effort to say that
Britain as an independent country
couldn't do well I thought that's very
disappointing and I understand why he
resigned I think now he is our foreign
secretary and I've always found him
friendly and easy to get on with he's a
great communicator he's very able I
think those are all great things in the
minister so I wish him every success and
now he is our foreign secretary but I
think he does need to
reassure uh the half of the country that
desperately wanted to leave the EU and
wants the government that strongly
believes in brexit and starts using
freedoms it's given us because we not
using many the freedoms we gain we need
reassurance from our foreign secretary
that his thinking has moved on that he
knows he's part of a brexit government
which was elected on that single pledge
ready to get brexit done and would he
help us get it done properly because
we're still too tied to some of the EU
laws and problems and there are huge
opportunities and he should above all
tell people as I do uh that our big win
already is that the EU is spending and
borrowing on a colossal scale and the UK
would have had um much bigger demands on
on our money for EU purposes and we'd
have had to guarantee the debts of
others through the EU borrowings and
isn't it great that we don't have that
added
complication in a difficult economic
situation Kate there's a lot of talk
about rishy trying to bring the Tory
party back to the center ground with by
bringing Cameron back uh and possibly
sort of pushing himself away from the
Tory right uh do you by that or do you
think it's media piffle I think bringing
David K back was really about putting
someone really serious in that very
important post at this time I also think
there was an element of sort of trusted
advisor I mean there is no doubt that as
a leader of a party especially a prime
minister when you come into an election
there is a bit of sort of loneliness of
power you know the weight of that falls
on your shoulders you you you're putting
yourself up for election on behalf of
your party I think having someone um
with you there who understands that
feeling will be you know really really
helpful to isi in terms of the sort of
center right I mean it does look I think
people think that because soel braan
left as David C came in so they see
those two together um but overall I
think that the reshuffle seemed to me to
be quite balanced he brought in Esther
McVey he's put in people that he likes
and respects this was his first time it
was much more his cabinet his government
he inherited really um from and didn't
want to fire a whole bunch of people
when he came in so I just think it's a
very personal set of appointments John
what what do you think about all the
talk of sunak effectively giving up on
the red wall uh trying to shore up the
blue wall with this
reshuffle well I don't think that's the
right interpretation and it would be a
crazy policy because you've got to
address both audiences and on some
issues the two audiences are actually
United they' both like some tax cuts and
some growth so that the kind of things I
recommend are designed to bring the
party together around good conservative
policies that would improve the economy
improve the lot of British people and
would actually be good news in in both
parts but I I don't think he's Cut Loose
from the red wo because his number
one aim he keeps on telling us is to
stop the small boats and and that's much
more popular in the red wall than it is
in the so-called blue wall seats where
more people more relaxed about numbers
of people coming into the country uh so
now I don't think he's given up on on
that at all I think what he's got to do
though um is to cut loose from some of
the extremely bad official advice he's
been getting on on everything from
migration to the economy and to
inflation because the the official
advice has been followed too slavishly
and we've ended up with borders are not
under control We've Ended up with an
inflation rate uh that was more than
five times the bank of England's Target
and more than five times the bank of
England's forecast and and we've ended
up with no growth at a time when uh you
can get the economy growing as we see
over the Atlantic with the United States
of America recording 4.9% growth in its
most recent figures despite itself
having a bit of a monetary problem and
crunch as well Kate you mentioned Zing
ping earlier uh and his authoritarian
turn uh he had a meeting with Joe Biden
yesterday uh which seems to have gone
fairly smoothly obviously differences of
opinion on lots of things and Joe Biden
at the end uh called CH jingping a
dictator again uh I'd like to ask you do
you think David Cameron thinks that zi
jingping is a dictator and how do you
you said earlier that he he's because
China has changed David Cameron's
position may have changed a little bit
but he hasn't changed Cameron hasn't
changed much on China it seems to me up
until very recently I mean only three
weeks ago he was in Sri Lanka uh
speaking in support of the Columbo Port
project which is a big China funed
project uh and I I accept that he wasn't
being paid directly by China or anything
but for that but yet it is clearly
supporting uh Chinese expansionism which
concerns a lot of people um how's he
going to handle
China so I mean obviously you you'll
have to ask him um that I mean look it
was interesting to see um Biden and she
meeting yesterday there is a sense that
um everyone in the west has become much
more uh scrutinizing of China especially
on the economic front so calling out um
concerns that they have over human
rights National Security and sovereignty
for us in Britain obviously Hong Kong is
top of that agenda um but the Americans
more focused on Taiwan and and that's
Focus for us too but there is also the
sort of economic Prosperity angle to
this and I'm talking about British
prosperity and I think you know we want
to try and find a balance don't we to
make sure that we we scrutinize but we
also make sure that we you know do trade
with one of the the biggest economies in
the world and it's a m it's about
finding a balance and being you know
really careful about it um I also got
the impression looking at that meeting
that you know the Americans are trying
you know to create some sort of they
don't want it to get out of hand when
the the Chinese balloon went up the
other day there was a concern that no
one knew who to phone it wasn't like the
old days with the Soviet Union where
they had this sort of red phone so I
mean there there the most important
relationship and I really hope we get
that right and I think we need to be
careful but we need to be addressing
British interest at all the time and
working with our allies especially in
the G7 which has become a really
functional unit um in terms of trying to
get this one right John what do you
think about that do you think uh the
last few years have shown that uh for
the global economy to function for the
West for America for Britain uh China is
just uh something we're going to have to
deal with we're going to have to work
with um and that people like David
Cameron and perhaps to a certain extent
Joe Biden uh have the right approach in
being accommodating uh where they
can well I don't think there's any point
in in making an enemy unnecessarily but
you've got to be realistic about China
and I think um the West has been very
unrealistic about China I think they
haven't understood uh just what a
brilliant strategy for China CH she has
developed in order to dominate markets
where we no longer have a strong
presence I mean for example it is the
West that is uh taking their respective
economies on on the road to Net Zero
China isn't China is still expanding her
CO2 output to the World on quite a big
scale and produces 30 times as much as
the UK and yet it is China that has
bought up all the reserves and
Technologies and put in the production
capacity to make the batteries and the
electric cars and the solar panels and
the wind turbines that we we may now
have to buy as imports from them and I
think this this shows that the West Was
negligent in the way it responded to the
the commercial challenge of China um
Kate says we need to protect the trade
there's any problem about protecting the
trade because it's more important than
export and China at the moment still
wants the the revenues from selling
things um the issue which
UK has got to Define for itself as
America is increasingly doing so for
herself is on what terms do you allow
Chinese trade and we are getting rightly
I think much more nervous about things
that entail technology sharing or
gifting or sending technology to the
Chinese uh given how good they are at
exploiting it and how we need basic
capabilities and basic producting
productive capacities that home uh for a
whole variety of self-sufficiency and
defense
reasons John and Kate I think we'll end
it there but thank you both very much
for joining spectator
[Music]
TV